nah what if you guess wasn't no one
caring no telling but they still take
you 1 correlate with you as an average
remember when you used to sell cheap
just to get establishing used to wear
the search with us things and get
embarrassed look doing everything seems
true with you but you really need to
stop making people keep using you like
who you have when you most need in here
so keep it real do you know who your
friends look they see a smell but never
know just was behind it I wish I had the
perfect words I probably could divide it
a lot of people want to see me film
which is ironic that even if I'm feeling
off you know i'm always on it I tend to
think about the things that may affect
me like I never study but they always
trying to test me and why you gotta get
me mad for you to just respect me should
I can't set it but i understand it yep i
play down but i'm far from a dummy it
was a point of my life when I felt ain't
no one would love me I was so insecure
to the pond started when studies and I
never tell the right especially when I
was getting ready I ain't be running
away hoping for a better way but then it
got hard so I came back within some
couple days and i was taking this with
discipline but turning pain never goes
away and I know I am not the only one
that talks to my soul I know why am I do
if you want some believe in your inbox
every week to keep you motivated check
out the link below to join my newsletter